Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am just checking in our home.
Ooh,
what's going on?
How are you?
I'm in Chicago.
My kind of town.
Chicago is my kind of town.
Chicago is eating harder attack foods.
Your cargo is a great place to put on 40 pounds.
It's my kind of town.
Yeah.
Oh,
they got steaks,
chops,
deep dish pizza.
You know,
I remember that old SNL sketch when they all dress like my dick care and they
all have in fucking heart attacks and stuff.
Yeah.
Uh,
this ends my sixth straight weekends on the road and I gotta tell you
I was in such great shape at the beginning of it and now I'm starting to go in
the wrong direction.
So it starts tonight.
Uh,
just ordered a little bit of room service,
something healthy,
something not so healthy.
But uh,
I'm fucking,
I got two shows tonight.
I'm just going to go home and you can tell him fighting off a fucking cold.
That almost ruined my show last night at Madison Square Garden.
Thank you to everybody who showed up.
I had a great God damn town time.
The sound was incredible.
And um,
I had a bunch of friends came out and saw it and they all were like,
oh my God,
we,
we really enjoyed it,
which made me feel good.
Thank you to the people,
you know,
some people gave me some gifts,
I got some cigars this week.
Thank you to everybody.
Came out to theF is for family.
Um,
thingamajig there that I did at the uh,
Paley Center with Mike Price and Peter Billingsley.
We actually aired the first episode for the people that were there.
We actually got a great review from Forbes magazine about our third season
saying it's her best fucking season and,
and,
and one of the top half hours on Netflix.
I mean,
I am having a hell of a week.
I really am.
I'm enjoying myself,
but I'm eating like a fucking idiot.
So drinking his stupid ass fucking vitamin C Shit.
You know,
don't just keep drinking those packets.
Psych.
Well,
it's a thousand milligrams.
What does drink two of them?
That's why I really went to thousand of anything in me.
Yeah,
that's,
it seems a like,
like a lot.
Can you o d on vitamin C,
you know
how many times can the cold virus kick vitamin C's ass before we realized that
it really doesn't do anything.
Vitamin C over dose,
you know,
somebody did this.
Okay.
Four adults,
the recommended daily amount for vitamin C's.
65 to 90 milligrams.
Now what do I got?
I got a thousand milligrams.
Uh,
and the upper limit is 2000 milligrams a day.
Although too much dietary vitamin C is unlikely to be harmful.
Mega doses of vitamin C supplements might cause diarrhea or nausea.
Okay.
And we can't,
Oh d on it be fucking hilarious if you get so into health that you fucking
overdosed the ugly truth behind the vitamin,
vitamin C overdose according to Spoon University,
uh,
that they'd like to snuggle when they learn things.
Spoon University.
I hate being sick and I'm guessing you do too,
says the article,
uh,
up up above Shamo.
See,
you've heard someone that you can never take too much vitamin C.
Is that really to trope or is it a myth?
Can we overdose environment and say,
I don't care.
I'm fucking,
if I'm reading,
just say the answer.
Okay.
Don't want to read an episode of a fuck a television show that doesn't exist.
It's an old person reading a book.
The other day at the airport I was just like,
wow,
that's fucking amazing.
You know,
they just didn't give in,
wasn't staring at a fucking smart phone like everybody else.
Clued myself,
you know,
I actually use my smartphone to help me with my stress.
Whenever I'm stressing out,
I just play fucking solitaire.
You know?
It's got a nice fucking mellow guitar thing.
Wayne,
Wayne.
Where when a barrel,
this fucking song,
it plays in the background and I just don't give a shit and try to beat my top
score and own.
I look up,
I was still in at the airport.
I don't give a fuck.
I really don't.
You know what I hate?
I hate when these fucking near the fucking security line at the airport and some
fucking asshole behind you goes.
It was so can I just get through them so by my flight's already boarding,
it's just like,
okay,
well you fucking going to miss it then
now because you're late because you're late,
you get rewarded for being late by not having to wait in the fucking line.
Like the rest of us.
Fuck you.
Fuck you and fuck your flight.
You know,
I'm sorry.
Can I just end in this stupid body language?
They're trying to be all like uh,
submissive as they walked past you.
I mean,
what's to stop somebody from just saying my flight leaves in fucking 10 minutes.
that's the move.
If you don't have TSA precheck or a global or a,
you know,
if you didn't have your taint mapped,
whatever the fuck they doing now to get you on the plane sooner.
I mean that's the move I think.
Yeah.
You're conspiracy theorist and you don't want them to have any more information
about you,
but you don't like waiting in lines.
I would just show up to,
yeah,
sorry.
It might make my flight leaves in 10 minutes.
Can I just,
can I get,
go age had a stairway cages.
Yeah.
Some of these to give those people the old right there,
Fred.
Oh God,
I'm fucking miserable.
If I can do these two shows tonight and not get sick,
if I can just fight it off.
MMM.
But anyways,
I had the greatest fucking night ever last night.
Just wire to wire.
I just had a fucking awesome set.
MMM.
Then the after party was at Gotham comedy club with the Mozillas who I've known
forever and uh,
they made this some credible cake.
MMM.
I believe they've got the cake boss to make it.
We took pictures.
I uploaded a shit,
but it was,
uh,
it was,
the cake was not only Madison Square Garden.
It also looked like a snare drum.
Cause you know,
obviously I played drums.
There was a helicopter on it and then they had this big figurine of me wearing
that fucking shirt.
I wore my last special with the stars on it.
And then,
uh,
they had the John Bonham screen sparkle 1971 Ludwig kit.
You know what,
this little Zeplin for insignia on it.
It was incredible.
Fucking cake was incredible.
And they let us,
well I can't see what they let us do cause I don't want to get them in fucking
trouble.
But you know something they usually make you do outside.
They allowed us to do insight,
which was fucking tremendous.
Um,
then that was it.
I didn't fucking went home.
And now I'm,
now I'm in Chicago,
I'm in fucking Chicago.
I got four shows here and uh,
the Chicago theater,
which arguably has the greatest marquis and the country,
I feel,
um,
speaking of the greatest,
uh,
Paul Versey special thanks to you guys
is a,
it's one of the highest rates specials,
comedy central sat in a long time.
It's fucking crushing.
It has over like a million views.
Um,
so thank you to everybody who went out and watched it.
It's still streaming on comedy central.
You can check it out.
It's great for Paul's.
Great for me.
Cause he did it with my company.
All things comedy by an Al Magicals,
you know,
it's fucking tremendous.
That's the first one.
And you know what?
We got three more common you'd take Paul offers.
He was was was the high watermark and we're going to dip.
Nope.
Everybody's is going to be at the same fucking level.
It's all going to be quality.
Um,
do I sound like Trump right now?
I actually watched a little bit of that news conference,
by the way.
You know,
that childish fucking affair,
Jesus Christ.
Everybody has a yelling at each other
report,
a continuing to ask questions.
It's Trump's saying I'm done with you.
Then he walked away from the microphone to that whole fucking thing on both
sides was like embarrassing.
Um,
and I'm not a fan of Trump,
but for people to sit there and act like the media does not fucking absolutely
hate that fucking guy.
I've never seen,
I mean,
I've never seen a guy get fucking attacked the way this fucking dude gets
attacked.
It's like a comic play a hell room.
He's just up there getting fucking heckled and he's like,
I'm not going to do my fucking act that I go do my act.
Ah,
you fucking suck.
Um,
I dunno.
It's the worst job on the fucking plant.
And you could literally get blamed for everything.
You know,
why not?
Why don't they fucking have a press conference with some of these fucking piece
of shit?
Corporations polluting the waters,
stealing from people,
blowing up the economy and then ripping the rug out from everyone.
What the fuck about them?
You become president.
You just,
you just,
they're fucking stooge and you go out there and you stand there and you just get
yelled at by these fucking nerds who think they're in the paper.
Chase is some shit.
Um,
I have no idea.
Another fucking bad story.
It's just a bad,
you know,
I just put it on the TV and I saw that whole thing about the fucking one of
those mass shootings.
Thanks.
And uh,
it just makes no sense that those things happen all the time.
Other than the fact that that's all they fucking show on TV.
And there has to be some sort of connection to that because there's always been
a shit of guns
and a shitload of people that had them.
And I,
I literally think like,
it's like the ice bucket challenge for Psychos and they just fucked me over that
everybody's so very during the ice bucket challenge.
So then everybody had to start dumping fucking water over their heads instead of
just giving money.
I never understood that.
It's like,
what is the cause?
Okay.
That's a good cause.
I mean,
I don't have to ruin my shirt for delay.
Would you like some money?
I'm willing to give you some.
So
I would love to see if they could experiment,
just not giving it any coverage
and then it would just fade away like an old pop star,
I think.
Okay.
You know,
I dunno.
That's my too,
because other than that,
I don't have any fucking solution for it.
MMM.
Just fucking horrific.
Oh,
anybody could fucking do something like that.
Um,
but anyways,
back to the comedy.
Back to the comedy.
Um,
oh my God.
This is one of these fucking day.
Some days doing a podcast is easy.
You know,
it's like falling out of bed.
Well that's not a fucking,
it's the one thing,
isn't it?
It's like getting out of bed,
rolling out of bed.
It's like taking a nap.
Is that an easy thing?
We asked people,
a hundred people did a survey said name the top five things are easy.
Yeah.
You know bad.
I would suck on fucking the family feud.
I keep saying the name of the shelter.
Family feud.
James.
Something that's easy to do.
Uh,
Mr. Byrd,
a fall out of bed,
show me fall out of bed,
back.
Sullivan family with a chance to steal.
I'd be that last family member.
You know what I mean?
Fucking dude all the way down the end.
You know,
families only have so many smart people and it seems what you watched a family
feud.
It stops around three.
Is there five people on a show was always the last to you know,
some,
we always just said something that sucks.
Well you should really do.
I think,
well how would you do that?
It's almost like a batting lineup with intelligence.
Okay.
Cause you got to have,
you lead off hitter.
You know,
you've got to have somebody bat and clean up and then he'd get,
you know,
you got your pitcher,
bat and knife.
If we're,
if we're going by national league rules here,
right?
What do you do?
Do you put the dummy up front when all the answers are still on the board?
Name a word that begins with a apple being number one answer,
right?
Or do you just leave that guy down the end
and hope that everybody else,
you know,
does a good job?
I wonder if there's fights.
You know when somebody finds out.
Yeah.
Hey,
we're going to have you all the way down to the end.
Basically the right field of intelligence.
We're going to have you all the way down the fucking end now as the person too
stupid to realize that that's where the dumbest person is.
You know,
everybody needs to get a hit.
Everybody needs to get ahead because this motherfucker's going to get a strike.
All right?
Just put him all the fuck way down.
He's going to get the least at bats.
In theory,
the APP,
they should have a fucking a week of,
of all those fucking people down the ends.
You know,
you just makes super families out of that last person.
Just the dumbest mother fuckers ever.
Oh,
where'd you call it?
Family feud of fucking dope week.
Who else that shows it's still Steve Harvey.
He would probably run on a looks to give the crowd.
Um,
anyway,
so I'm hearing in Chicago this buckets and I gotta I gotta I gotta get back on
my God damn diet.
You know,
I was looking good before I did this six week run.
I had my whole fucking future ahead of me.
You know,
it's fucking hilarious.
I'm going to the heart doctor next week.
If you get my ticker checked out,
uh,
six weeks ago,
that gang or in phenomenal shape for your age,
and I was going to be like,
hey,
you probably want to lose seven pounds.
I can do it though.
I'm going to be that.
You know what I'm going to be,
I'm going to be that fucking guy that loses weight during the holidays.
You know,
he was only one way to do that.
You gotta be homeless.
Nobody loves you
because I don't care how much of an asshole you are.
When it's the holidays,
somebody is going to make cookies,
right?
Those stupid little tins.
You walk over and you open it up,
you know,
is that voice in the back of your head?
What are you doing?
And then you shout it down with,
you know,
I'm going to go to the gym in January.
I'm going to start the year with a giant fucking
steamship round for a fucking torso.
I can't do it,
man.
MMM.
I'm disgusted with myself.
Look what you dead,
Bill.
You had a good thing going.
You fucking ruined it.
Um,
I haven't watched any sports.
I don't even know what's going on anymore.
Right?
Red Sox won the world series and I just been fucking flying high.
I haven't watched anything.
I know the late.
What about fucking Duke?
Just absolutely kicking the fucking shit out of Kentucky.
It once again.
Once again,
they,
they got it.
They got another guy.
How do they fucking do it?
Duke Verse Kentucky.
Now,
how does that work to do they just have this shit just to like for the ratings
so they can figure out who's,
uh,
who's the best team?
Does this actually count?
Is it like soccer where they have a friendly chat up?
You know,
soccer's is like that.
we're playing but it doesn't,
it doesn't mean anything.
MMM.
That's 75,
47 with 14 minutes to go.
Are you fucking kidding me?
They scored 75 points and a half.
I think.
You just can't be
okay.
It can't be
one 18 to 84.
That's like a fucking NBA score.
Yeah.
They still let up 84 points,
so
I dunno.
I Dunno how to fuck that works,
but it did somehow.
I'll tell you what.
They have Duke Blue Devils.
They put a weapon on that fucking wild cats from Kentucky.
All right,
let me do a couple of reads here.
Everybody a Saucy,
everyone at some point,
his wish,
they could just have a,
just have beer,
wine or liquor delivered while someone filing decided to do something about it.
Introducing Staffie,
the alcohol delivery APP.
Southie delivers your favorite wine,
beer,
and liquor,
right to [inaudible] on demand.
Now,
if he'll now,
if you live in Los Angeles,
the bay area,
Chicago,
San Diego,
or Sacramento years,
I'll say,
order will arrive at your [inaudible] and under 30 minutes.
Ready to drink.
Now,
why didn't they say Los Angeles,
the bay area,
San Diego,
Sacramento,
and then Chicago.
This is how long I've been on the tour.
I'm like,
that fucking routing sucks.
And we meet La.
I go up to San Francisco,
Oakland,
then I go over to Chicago,
back to San Diego and up to Sacramento.
The fuck are we doing here?
Uh,
for the rest of US saucy.
We'll deliver it.
Beer,
wine and liquor to you.
Deal with it in two days or less.
Nationwide.
Um,
there are no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
Uh,
if you got the saucy APP,
yeah,
you got a fully stocked by on your fault and for a limited time you can get $50
off.
When you doubt.
Wait,
I'm in Chicago.
They can deliver.
We selected by kind of booze with saucy baby.
We delivered to La and fucking saucy and fuck.
In the bay area,
there are no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
If you've got the saucy app,
you got a fully stocked bar on your phone.
And for a limited time you can,
you can get $15 off when you download this saucy happen at a Promo Code Burr,
that saucy APP,
spelled s a,
u c e y en.
Enter the Promo Code burpee.
You are a for $50 off.
Get the saucy app today and use Promo Code Bar.
Oh look who's here.
But Dude,
dude,
[inaudible] days [inaudible] fucking steak dude,
dude.
[inaudible] it's fall.
Grab a rake,
ate a bunch of pizza and fucking fat and infoed walk around like a Mustachio
dude cause you're in Chicago.
Block your arteries with all their fucking delicious food and not of itself fee
while your balls roll around on felt,
uh,
Biondi is uses the coveted micro modal modal fabric,
which is three times softer than cotton.
Pete never felt this fabric.
Get ready to experience pure bliss in underwear form men and women can choose
from four different cuts,
all of which are available from classic colors too.
Adventurous Prince.
Speaking of Prince this holiday season.
Oh the holiday season.
Beyond these we'll be releasing a new fucking bread every God damn Tuesday that
made you have no excuse to celebrate the holidays right down to your very own
car.
Uh,
but why stop it be this year me undies is launching their holiday prince in
lounge
pants and Wednesdays as well.
Both are made from the same micro modal modal fabric as their undies.
Seriously,
how could he get not,
but how can you not get you at your loved one?
A matching holiday themed one z this year.
Okay.
Cause it's kind of weird to be an adult wearing a fucking onesy.
It'd be like one of those,
those adult babies,
you know,
sit in a fucking crib cause you can't deal with reality.
Well I guess,
you know,
it's just another segment of the population they're trying to make money off of.
So you know,
God bless them beyond.
He's has a great offer for my listeners.
For first time purchasers,
purchase your shares when you purchase any BMV should get 50% off and free
shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 50% off the most comfortable on you will ever put on to get your 50% off
your first pair of free shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to me undies.com/bird.
That's me.
undies.com/bar.
All right,
what's left?
Oh,
butcher box,
right?
Butcher box.
That reminds me,
I looked up battleaxe today since the fucking funny thing,
Eh,
I tried to tucked in that fucking battle ax over there.
You know,
I always thought that meant an ugly woman.
It just means a woman who doesn't take any shit and she's difficult.
Right.
You know,
I dunno.
I always thought like a battle ax.
It looked bad.
It was all fucked up looking cause she went to battle on it.
So you've seen her face look like a battle ax?
I guess it wasn't though.
They determined.
Let's look up the definition of bad actually.
Like God,
call your wife that and see what the fuck happens,
eh?
Yeah.
Fucking battle ax.
All right.
Battleaxe meaning is a term generally considered a pejorative?
Do you know?
Many times I've looked up pejorative.
That's like when they said the Democrats won the house.
I was like,
oh my God,
what does that mean?
Every election I have to look up.
What does the fucking house do versus what does the Senate though?
I thought they were all,
I don't think all is at the Capitol is one side of the house.
The other side's the Senate.
I Dunno.
Whenever you,
I just picture you go in there and all you hear is the sound of loafers walking
on marble.
Alright.
Expressing contempt or disapproval.
Pejorative.
Can you use it and explore in a sentence please?
Oh,
it gives a fuck.
I don't even care anymore.
Right.
A battleax you fucking battle ax whenever.
I see.
Okay.
So it's,
well,
what just happened?
Oh,
there it is.
All right.
A battle ax is a term generally considered pejorative for an aggressive,
domineering,
and forceful woman.
Oh,
this is the female word for cock sucker guys.
Dick.
Uh,
she's a fucking battleaxe and he's a fucking Dick.
Battleaxe it's just funnier.
The battleax is one of several stereotypes found in nursing,
a tyrannical,
fierce matron exemplified by nurse ratchet or Haiti's shock and popular medical
dramas and comedies.
Why the fuck?
Why is everybody picking on nurses?
I Dunno.
It's kind of my goal this week.
I'm going to call somebody a battleax.
I would never call my wife that she's too fucking.
What's the worst thing?
I have a call with my wife.
I don't call.
I don't,
I don't do the name.
Call it thick most.
How do we stop being such a fucking asshole?
Leave me alone.
Just leave me alone.
All right.
What's your box?
Everybody?
Butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and Ah,
heritage bread.
Pork.
Oh,
do you owe it to yourself to eat one of those fucking pigs?
The incredible quality of butcher box meets,
start with the commitment to raising animals humanely free of antibiotics and
hormones before they murdered them.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals or one and a half meals for a binge
eater when those little skinny Asian guys,
if for some reason when the hot dog eating contest right and the big fat dude
kid can't get it done,
you can choose from five different box types,
all beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork,
mixed box or custom box
which lets you choose your own cuts.
All right.
Personal experience.
I already told you guys told you many times that heritage bread pork mean it's
pure bred.
It's like it's the original pigs from Europe for whatever reason they taste
better than the ones we got over here.
You know,
probably because our pigs around eat fucking Mcdonald's,
you know,
grew up on peanut butter and fluff it out or some shit.
I don't know what the hell these fucking
uppity goddamn heritage breed pork with doing,
but whatever they did it,
they did.
It tastes fucking delicious.
Anyways,
for $20 off your first box in two pounds of free ground beef in every box for
the life of your subscription.
That's $20 off your first box in two pounds of free meat a month.
That's a lot of fucking meat quarter pounder,
right?
That'd be eight quarter pounders.
How many days?
And we're not month.
Well built,
depends on the month.
All right,
relax.
And for people who are already butcher box subscribers,
you'll have a special deal on ground beef you can take advantage of by logging
into your account.
Go to butcher,
butcher box.com/burr and enter Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
Once again,
butcher box.com/burr and enter burr at checkout.
Okay.
All right,
let's get back to this fucking bullshit over here.
Let me see.
You know,
I'm gonna look at this.
This just,
I'd like to search and dumb shit like this.
Top 10 worst things you can call your,
okay.
Oh girlfriend.
Here we go.
I just popped up.
All right,
let's see what we got here.
But up up,
up as,
let's play the feud.
Alright,
let's see.
My 10 number one would be content.
Number two would be bitch
a horse gotta be in their slot.
Battle ax.
Haffer
uh,
Jesus Christ.
That's all I got.
That's going to be something else.
What else can I call you fucking,
uh,
that was kind of covers it,
right?
Bimbo,
dumb,
dumb.
I'm just run.
Just becoming a fucking second grader.
All right.
The 10 worst things you can call a female who may see this list.
What,
how did I end up looking this up?
What the fuck is wrong?
The 10 worst things you can call a woman.
Number 10,
bitch,
this is probably the most common term.
You straight into the point yet not as degrading because of its immense
popularity in common use.
Well,
it depends on,
on,
yeah.
Like
I think if black women,
if you call him a bitch at me and it's means more white women for some reason
why we've been really don't like content.
And I think white people say cunt a lot.
I don't know that black people say content,
which would be fucking hilarious.
Um,
at least American black people.
I haven't seen it,
you know,
not like I'm out here doing a cut survey,
but I'm just generally speaking the people that I talked to,
uh,
anyways,
I find black people will add,
you know,
add to bitch stank bitch or something like that.
But they never seem to make the leap to cut
white people like bitches.
Just sad.
She's a bitch.
You know what?
She's really being a bitch.
She's a cut and that's how it works.
Everybody.
All right,
number nine cow.
Speaking of butcher box cow,
the only reason this is so low on the list is because it never comes as a
surprise of fat.
Chick knows she's a fetch Jesus Christ.
She knows she's a fat chick.
In fact,
sometimes they even embrace it.
So in rare cases,
this going actually backfire.
Now I don't think,
I don't think this works.
I don't,
I don't believe in that.
And who wants to be called a fucking cow?
That is funny though.
If fucking cow
cows funny than pig.
When you say you fat pig,
you're fat cow.
There's something about cow.
Maybe it's the sound.
It's is out.
You know,
this hours in there,
it hurts.
It's a hurtful thing.
Slut
number seven,
horse slash po number six is slob.
Wait a second.
I didn't mind when you called me a whore,
but when you said I was a Slob,
that was it.
Skank pig.
Bimbo,
slut smut bag.
Oh,
this is worse than my list and it can't.
Yup.
You knew camp was going to be number one.
All right.
Now let's now let's be fair.
Let's be fair to the ladies here.
All right.
Top 10 worst things you can call your boyfriend.
This is how you killed time on the road as a comedian,
by the way.
Uh,
all right.
This is hilarious.
Women have 25 things that they call guys.
They really do talk more,
don't they?
25 wars.
Pet names for your lover thinks you don't want to call your lover.
50 horrible nicknames for your significant other.
13 was pet names.
Yeah.
What not to say to your boyfriend?
All right,
here we go.
I would imagine when he takes his dick out,
they go.
Is that it?
It tickles.
Um,
all right.
Number one,
you're so much better than all the other jerks I dated.
Yeah.
Cause that makes them a meal to think,
well,
how much cock has been in you?
Uh,
can you really afford that?
Yeah.
This is just one of these classic things.
It's like today,
even ask guys,
can you really afford that?
Can you really afford that?
Uh,
yeah,
I can.
Or No,
I can't.
Thank you for stopping me from making this bad purchase.
That seems like a concern,
girlfriend.
So we're running a little late.
Relax.
All right,
so we're running a little late.
Comes with the territory.
But if there's a preemptive relaxed before I flipped out,
that would bug me.
Although I don't know if this makes my top 10.
He's a great guy.
You should be friends with him.
Yeah.
That means you guys used to fuck.
Are you about ready to number five?
She made me promise not to tell,
but uh,
it's not surprising then that you can keep your fucking mouth shut.
Code guys.
Number six.
Don't be silly.
I haven't done that.
Ne Just,
okay.
Uh,
I dunno what that means.
What would we,
what are we talking about?
You want some heroin?
Don't be silly.
I haven't done that in ages.
Can I put it in your ass?
Don't be silly.
I haven't done that day.
Just say,
yeah,
it's kind of a weird answer.
No matter what you are asking.
Would you like some cereal?
Don't be silly.
I haven't done that in ages
anyways.
Number 10.
Oh 10 sentences.
He be psyched to hear.
Yeah.
Number one,
boy.
Nothing helps me wind down after a long day at work.
Like,
yeah,
giving you a blowjob.
Okay.
That's never been said.
Number two,
what does this became like wacky Dick Jokes.
All right.
That was cosmo.
Everybody.
Um,
all right.
I need to drink more fucking,
I guess vitamin C,
it's inevitable.
I'm going to,
I got to do two shows tonight.
All right.
Oh,
freckles is going to get sick first cold of the year.
Didn't even make it to fucking December,
you know.
All right,
well thank you once again to everybody who came out to Madison Square Garden.
Thank you to uh,
Gotham comedy club for the after party.
Thank you for to the west side comedy club for helped me tune up my shit earlier
in the week.
Uh,
uh,
I think that's it.
Take it.
Everybody showed up.
All right.
Enjoy the music and a,
uh,
continued special half hour of a,
I guess greatest hits from a Thursday podcast from earlier this year or 10 years
ago.
I have no idea.
Oh,
by the way,
I got some great fucking video to backstage that we will be putting up on the
Patriot page,
uh,
from the beginning of the show and the end of the show.
Very excited about it.
Um,
that is all,
have a great weekend.
You bitches.
I can't say cotton,
right?
I don't wanna offend you.
Alright.
You're slobs or your doctor.
Listen to podcasts
and miles away from me.
You couldn't see how I am
so close.
So close.
Carry your books from school.
I was six when we came
when you were a baby and your crew
to look down at you
day.
My son will grow to be a,
okay,
well look at you now.
Sheila's got your asses whipped by a bunch of God damn nerds.
Yeah.
Well,
if I was you,
I'd do something about it.
I would get up and redeem myself.
The eyes of my father,
my maker,
and my coach who was dead.
Hey,
it's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
November eight,
2010.
Hope these levels aren't too fucking high ahead to really crank that up so you
could actually hear that speech that I hope there's actually some New England
patriots listening that will,
that that goes out to the New England patriots.
Everybody after that fucking shall lacking that rape that they took at the hands
of the fucking hapless Cleveland Browns,
the fucking hapless Cleveland browns.
Why are these levels so fucking high?
Hang on a second.
Hang on.
It's going on here.
Hello.
Test One,
two bill [inaudible] Monday morning podcast.
There we go.
Is that better?
Um,
Jesus Christ,
we got fucking killed.
Absolutely fucking killed,
uh,
by a white running back.
Everybody.
You know something.
I'm going to go out on a limb.
I think the white running back or fullback.
Let's not get crazy now.
Let's not get crazy.
The fullback,
that fucking white dude who just doesn't feel pain it Punahou fucking kill that
guy.
That dude is back Mongo.
Remember that fucking white dude who rode the bull in blazing saddles?
Put a helmet on that guy.
That's who the fucking Pat's went up against yesterday.
Jesus Christ.
You should have seen this fucking guy.
He had a face mask,
his face mask look like the front of a dodge ram pickup truck looked like the
grill of that dodge ram pickup truck.
The second you see his face mask,
you know what he's doing?
He's getting the ball.
He's going right up the fucking middle.
He's out running around the side like some fairy fucking running back.
He's coming right up to fucking gut.
And that's exactly what that guy did all God.
Damn Day long.
He was stiff arming a defensive ends,
like they were cornerbacks just sort of throwing them aside.
It was,
it was one of the most dominating performances that I've seen in a while.
And,
uh,
so that was a little inspirational speech for my team because next week we play
in the Pittsburgh.
And,
uh,
I was already worried about that game.
But,
uh,
this is the interesting thing about how football works is if the Patriots went
in and actually beat the browns.
Um,
I was thinking that,
okay,
if we beat the browns and then we'd go up seven in one,
we are going to get at what happened in Cleveland was going to happen in
Pittsburgh.
But now for some fucking reason,
this is how it seems to work that we lost in Cleveland.
We'll actually be way more competitive.
I still think we're going to lose in Pittsburgh.
Our defense is fucking horrific.
It's horrific.
You know,
it's fucking frustrating to be going through.
it's actually not bad.
We go through a fucking,
uh,
a a a rebuilding year,
you know,
and I know a lot of you guys out there just cause it's the patriots.
You still think it's the fucking championship team.
Go get yourself a little team roster thing and look who's left.
You know,
our whole offense is built around,
thrown to rookie fucking tight ends.
And Brady was off yesterday,
kept throwing everything through the fucking roof,
right?
I'm sitting there talking to these people in this sports bar actually found a
cool one where it was kind of mellow and there wasn't really a,
you know,
there's like this insane one around the corner where people,
it's just like,
you can't even go in there with your team colors on because if your team is
losing that day,
you're going to want to fight somebody.
It's one of those places and it's just not an enjoyable experience.
So I found this other one where they have like nice,
like,
you know,
it's just nice.
The decor is nice.
It doesn't have that fucking date rape vibe,
like a lot of sports bars.
Do,
you know,
that fucking awful vibe.
The pent up just fucking the,
the amount of fucking,
uh,
pent up,
you know,
and then they got the,
those fucking girls always got to dress like runaways.
The waitresses,
it's just creepy.
The whole fucking vibe is creepy.
I don't like it.
And it's just,
yeah,
this is awful.
So I found this other sports bar that was,
you know,
actually way more mellow.
And I'm sitting there,
right.
And I come walking in it.
By the time I get there,
it's already tend enough and Cleveland and I sit down as this dude next to me
already drinking beers.
The game comes on at like fucking 10 in the morning and he's clearly on like his
third beer.
I didn't realize that it would shift face.
I go,
Jesus Christ,
they go 10 to nothing.
I go,
what happened?
And he looks at me,
he's like,
Cleveland is up 10 nothing.
I was just like,
all right man.
Thank you.
Thank you for fucking a
thank you for clearing that up.
You know,
um,
and Jesus Christ and they just start.
It was awful.
We just got the living shit kicked out of.
And you know what was funny was last week,
this week I got,
I got a ton of emails from jets fan.
So it was very surprising because last week I didn't get any from him.
You know,
last week when they lost to the packers,
nine to nothing at home.
I got like two emails from jets fans and then this week it was weird,
you know,
cause I was like,
wow,
I did do the jets fans not exist anymore.
Then this week all of a sudden I get this whole avalanche.
Okay,
well look,
I know all jet fans and all sports fans aren't like that because a lot of you
didn't send me emails either fucking way.
But those,
those fucking sports pussies who fucking lay in the weeds until that team wins
and then they get out and start talking shit.
You know,
let me ask you guys is because I've been just sitting here trashing the jets all
year.
It does.
Let me ask you this real honestly,
honestly,
do you really think you're going to win the super bowl at that team?
You know,
because I have such blind hatred for the fucking jets after the shit talk and
that they did at the beginning of the year.
Honestly.
Do you really think that that team has,
what the fuck it takes?
All right,
set aside your ha seriously eking out a victory against the lions.
You eked out a victory against the dolphins and you eat one out against the
Broncos.
Two out of three of those games were not for a bonehead fucking penalty by the
other God damn team.
You know,
you could have lost one or maybe both of those to add to your two fucking
losses.
Now,
if I'm a jet fan,
I gotta be thinking no,
I got to be thinking,
the one thing I got going for myself
is that nobody is dominating in the AFC.
Nobody is,
you know,
that's the one thing that I would take.
I would take pride in the fact because the jets have not really dominated
anybody.
Have they?
They kicked the shit out of the Patriots,
but that wasn't until the sec,
oh actually we'll is this second half,
second half after the second quarter they did.
But other than that,
I dunno,
I'm not too impressed.
I think that they're fucking offensive line might be the best in the league and
Sanchez just sits back there in a fucking launch here.
But I think if they actually go up against,
I dunno
the giants,
I,
yeah,
I just,
I don't fucking see it.
You know what I'm basically saying is that when Joe Nemeth finally dies,
I hate to say it,
I think you guys going to have to get them stuffed and mounted so you can still
wheel them out into the field to get you to get that.
He's like,
you're newt Rockne and then he can stick one of those things in the side of his
neck where you,
uh,
will you just pull the fucking you Paul it and the string and he starts talking.
I think the Jetson going to make a great play.
I want to kiss you.
You just have it sorta half fucking shit faced.
Half inspirational speech.
Oh,
Jesus.
So next week we play the fucking Steelers and uh,
I dunno,
I dunno what's going to happen.
I think we're actually going to have a nice competitive fucking game with them
somehow.
It makes no sense,
which is why I have to stop fucking gambling because I got to admit as much.
Um,
I can't even say it really hurt because I don't give a fuck about Cleveland.
and I also,
you know,
it's no surprise that our defense sucks.
Um,
the game that pissed me off the most yesterday was the fucking Kansas City
chiefs game.
The,
this,
these were my pics yesterday.
Okay.
I got this thing going on,
Paul Versey,
right?
Um,
you've got to pick four games a fucking week.
The end of the year,
the guy takes the pot,
right?
So I got the cheat,
I got the,
I got the bears against buffalo bears given three.
I tied that game,
right?
Then I picked Tampa and Tampa against Atlanta.
Get an eight and a half.
I fucking won that game.
I had green bay given seven,
whatever the fuck against the hapless fucking cowboys,
right to oh in one.
Nobody's gone undefeated.
I had the fucking Kansas City chiefs,
those fucking assholes.
One that Goddamn game and just decided to give it away.
Uh,
I really want to blame the fucking refs,
but it at that fucking Matt Cassel,
he just,
he just drove me fucking nuts.
Those fucking receivers not catching the ball.
I'll do kip.
Fuck the Kansas City chiefs.
Fucking God damn asshole.
Do you see that fucking call chiefs fans?
You see,
you see that pass interference call the end of the fucking game when the Raiders
were down by two.
I can see this is why I think it's fixed and this is why I think I'm good.
I would never gamble other than just with a buddy.
Like I don't,
I honestly,
I don't know how you fucking gamblers do it because the level of fucking
emotions that you go through when you have money on the game is nothing.
Nothing compared to you.
Just love and your hometown teen,
all those fucking douchebags Lou go out to the Raiders games.
Then they fucking dress like Spock or whatever the fuck it is.
Spock with like spikes coming out of his shoulders.
As much as they think that they give a fuck.
You know,
you don't give a fuck as much as some guy who's not even from Oakland,
who's got money on that fucking game.
I'm telling you why the fucking levels.
So God damn low,
think it's time to get a new,
uh,
recorded here.
People have been bitching a little bit saying the levels are a little bit quiet
here.
You gotta make sure I got this shit going here.
Hello?
Test one.
There we go.
All right.
So anyways,
when that fucking ref called that pass interference and then they show the
replay and the announcers are just like,
oh,
let's see what's going on here.
Uh,
doesn't seem to be any contact.
Well Jay,
Mike,
I'll tell you I didn't see anything and then they just continue on.
Nobody starts going,
well,
why the fuck?
How the fuck do you call something that didn't even happen,
you know?
I mean,
I can see missing some shit that happened.
It's like fucking 22 God damn people out there running around out of fuck.
He supposed to see everything.
But how do you call some shit that didn't even fucking happen.
I swear to God,
I think it's fucking fixed on some level.
Something fucked up is going on.
And I challenged my listeners.
I right,
you fuckers defend that.
How is,
you know,
I don't like to sound like such an asshole who lost money on a fucking game.
How do you call some shift?
It didn't happen.
I get at 22 fucking people.
I get how you can miss something.
It's like standing in grand central station.
Everybody's going every which way.
So I'm like,
oh my God.
Do you see that?
Then homeless guy just took a shit on the floor.
Did you see that?
Actually I didn't.
I was staring at that checks.
Ticks.
I missed it.
I get that.
But how do you call die?
Death.
Fucking 15 yards for shitting on the floor and there's no shit on the,
on the floor.
That's such a stupid fucking example.
This is how mad I was so fucking mad when the rest miss that God damn call and
gave in fuck it.
And I didn't miss the call.
Just invented that fucking call.
Get the fucking Raiders are first down.
And I see that that fat fuck dude who got caught with the date rape drug warming
up his leg and I know he can kick it from fucking Siberia.
So items like this game's fucking over.
It's going to go into OT and I shut the game off and I just,
I,
I picked up the remote control and I just started fucking just,
just,
just slamming it methodically.
Like that fucking Slingblade guy.
I'll write it down on Dwight Yoakam's fucking head.
Just,
just,
I actually,
I got so fucking mad at a,
at a just courtesy to my girl.
I just,
I walked,
I grabbed my phone,
I have fucking Hoodie and I just started walking,
started walking up the street like,
fuck,
I didn't know where I was going.
Rex fucking cock get fucking piece of shit.
Fucking vets.
No fucking way.
I'm gonna fuck you fucking call something.
That didn't even fucking happen.
I should be three Erwin fucking book people walking by with their pugs just
staring at me.
I'm trying to act like I'm talking on my cell phone.
I'm not talking to myself.
I'm talking to that fucking ref,
that piece.
Shit Ref.
I swear to God,
if I was running the fucking league and at the end of the game,
some fucking ref made a God damn call that that overtly affected the point
spread and he made a call.
It didn't even fucking happen.
That son of a bitch would be in my office Monday fucking morning,
I'd have his phone bill laying on the table,
his visa,
mastercard bills,
his fucking passport,
all of his shit.
And I would be looking at his life and I would figure out who the fuck this guy
owes money to that you can make a a horseshit call like that.
All right,
I'm back.
And that's what happened to me.
I fucking walked up the hill is so God damn pissed.
I started walking into the Goddamn hills,
walking up to the street and it took,
the sun's going down,
right?
I get to the top of the Goddamn hill and I realize I'm right at the foot of this
fucking park that has a bunch of God damn coyotes,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm not there.
I'm not there with my fucking pit bull.
I don't have my security with me.
And I'm just walking up there and then I was thinking like,
Jesus Christ,
what if I get mauled to death
by a pack of coyotes?
That would be the dumbest death ever comedian,
Malta,
death by coyotes because the chiefs didn't cover against the Raiders.
And right there I was just like,
you know what?
This gambling shit is the dumbest shit you can ever do to yourself.
If you've never gambled,
don't do it.
Don't put money on a game.
It literally,
it ruins your football Sunday.
It fucking ruins it.
It's losing money on a game.
I'm telling you is so much worse than just watching your team loose.
You know,
your team loses,
they fucking lose,
but you still,
you can still go out and go buy yourself a slice of pizza.
Right.
You know,
maybe that key chain you had your eye on.
All right,
that's enough.
That's enough with the sports this fucking week,
I believe.
Um,
so congratulations to the Co,
AH,
the Cleveland browns fans.
I'm actually in some weird way.
It's kind of hard cause you beat my team.
I'm actually excited that you guys look like maybe you finally pick the right
quarterback after years of,
you know,
the Cleveland browns assault,
kind of like the Chicago bears or the East,
you know,
where they just,
I don't know,
they always get that Cade mcdowney Tim couch or whatever the fuck his name or
the always get that guy,
that guy who was the fifth runner up Heisman trophy guy,
you know,
and they did it again this year with Colt Mccoy and he,
he looked great.
He fucking look great.
Stepping up into the pocket,
ran one for a touchdown.
He was fucking rolling out throwing the ball on the run.
Like fucking Doug Flutie.
I Dunno,
whatever.
What the fuck are you going to do?
God dammit,
we've got raped.
She got raped and Cleveland,
uh,
right next to the rock and roll hall of fame.
Just to add insult to injury.
And then I got to get all these emails from these jets fans.
You know,
they were all laying in the fucking weeds,
just waiting for the Patriots to lose.
You know,
I was amazed at how quickly I got the emails from them considering they had to
clean four quarters in one OT of shit out of their pants.
Um,
if you are going to,
if you are going to gamble,
I got to tell you,
I met the cat might be out of the bag,
but there's a,
I love teams right now like Cleveland,
the lions.
Um,
who else?
There's was one other one.
The rams.
If those teams are on the road and they're getting any sort of sizeable points,
uh,
I would go with those guys just because they have competitive fucking teams.
Like,
uh,
they just,
Brian's had a great fucking draft and they keep,
they keep being like fucking five point underdogs and that type of shit.
I don't know.
Then they blow it in the fucking,
and that's the only thing.
Cause if they let up a touchdown,
then you loo ads all fucking fixed.
How could it not be fixed?
How do you know?
How do they pick the,
the,
the perfect fucking number,
every God damn week.
How do they do that?
You know,
if it's so fucking hard for me,
I don't get it.
Like literally be like if I picked one game a week,
I should have a 50 50 chance of winning it.
Right.
And after 16,
17 weeks with the buy,
I should be,
you know,
501 game I'll over one game under,
right.
I should be nine and eight or eight and nine and it never works out that way.
Somehow you,
you lose like 60% of the fucking time.
I don't get it there.
Any mathematicians out there that can fucking help me out.
I'm all God damn years.
That piece of Shit fucking rough.
This is what happens too.
When you gamble,
then you start fucking no in the names of referees and that's when you have a
fucking problem.
You start knowing the names of backup punters.
I guess some people know that shit nowadays.
Those fantasy football playing people did that got him on my fantasy team.
Um,
what the fuck are my questions for the week?
All right.
That was 20 minutes of sports.
I really good.
Let's,
let's talk politan.
Let's talk,
let's talk politics.
The elections where this past week,
where are you guys excited?
Are you excited that we took the country back?
How many times are we going to do that in these elections?
You know,
like two years ago,
I remember everything was the Republican's fault and then they vote in all
democrats and people like,
yeah,
we took the country back,
right?
Two years,
fucking later,
they vote in all Republicans and they say the exact same fucking thing.
This is the theme this week is that everything is fucking rigged.
You can't tell me you,
you can't.
You don't notice
that no matter who you put in now it doesn't really make a difference at this
sort of,
this,
this common,
the tone,
this,
the same line.
Anybody,
anybody noticed that?
None of them are talking about bankers and how they took $1 trillion.
No one's talking about that and just kept the shit.
No one's talking about that.
No one's talking about,
uh,
how all these companies have fucking taken all the manufacturing out of this
country.
We probably need to reverse NAFTA.
They'd probably be a good fucking idea.
No one's talking about that Democrat or Republican,
the Algebra,
I think it's time to get this God fee back to work.
Everybody starts screaming like something's going to fucking happen.
You know,
Federal Reserve just printed another $600 million out of thin fucking air and is
buying up bonds.
It's,
nobody's didn't,
nobody's talking about that shit.
Nothing,
nothing.
All they're talking about is fucking family values and getting people back to
work and a hard working Americans and all this lip service,
you know,
and then people vote Democrat and Republican,
right?
Which is,
you're fucking right.
But then whenever I tell him I voted for,
uh,
somebody outside those two parties who actually says,
hey,
why don't we audit the Federal Reserve?
Why don't we figure out why they're a private corporation yet somehow print the
money for this country.
They always tell me that that's a waste of a vote.
So then you vote for fucking,
I don't get it.
I really don't fucking get it.
So I don't give a shit.
This whole country's going down the fucking shit.
Everybody's just sitting there yelling at each other,
fucking tea party screaming at people.
I fucking give it thought,
you know,
I just find the whole thing unbelievably fucking a depressing.
I think the world is run by sociopath's and who manipulate morons.
You know,
you got this whole sea of morons could fill up the Pacific Ocean with the amount
of morons,
you know,
tell me what to thank those people and then the sociopath.
Tell them what to think and whoever's the best at telling them what to think
wins.
Gi Bill.
That was fucking deep.
I know.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking above.
You know what it is?
I just like the people who,
uh,
I don't know.
I got my immune to explain it.
I just slides just like people who just go,
this,
this is bullshit.
This is fucking fixed.
I like those guys.
I don't like people who go,
uh,
you know,
you know who were the Jesus,
you know what?
This podcast went off the fucking rails at least three minutes ago.
I don't even want to say,
you know what?
I'm so fucking stupid that I don't even realize that I'm one of those morons in
the Pacific Ocean,
that Herei am trying to have this deep fucking thought about politics.
And I don't even have the fucking wherewithal,
the brainpower
to even convey my own thoughts.
So with that,
let's go with the obscure sports stat of the week.
This is a new,
this is for all the,
the,
the sports nerds out there.
Uh,
this is the obscure sports stat of the week.
This is a new segment.
All right?
This is something I didn't realize is how much,
um,
teams from Massachusetts from Boston have dominated St Louis.
Here's the,
this,
I was in Saint Louis two weeks ago and a,
somebody hit me,
hit me with this stat.
All right,
well,
the last time the St Louis Cardinals,
uh,
lost a world series they lost to the Boston red sox.
The last time the city of St Louis lost the Superbowl.
They lost the New England patriots.
The last time the city is St Louis lost to Stanley Cup finals game.
They lost to the Boston Bruins.
Add the most obscure of obscure the last time St Louis lost an NBA finals in
1960 61 the St Louis Hawks lost to the Boston Celtics.
We fucking own you guys.
St Louis.
You hear me?
We've owned you sent 60,
61 and what have you done about it?
Nothing.
I'm all right.
I'm bored shitless with sports too.
Let's,
let's move on here.
What do we got here?
Oh,
last week I asked you guys,
you know I was talking about that woman who kept clearing her throat in a really
annoying way behind me on the plane.
And I presented this question to you.
I said,
what would happen if the most interesting man in the world met the most annoying
woman on the planet?
What would happen?
And I asked you guys for your theories and I got a bunch of them and I'm going
to try to read them now and not fuck it up.
Um,
this is what people had to say without saying a word.
He can make even the biggest con shut up and do the fucking dishes because he is
the most interesting man in the world.
All right.
That's story number one.
Theory number two,
most entering,
most interesting man plus contiguous woman equals most miserable man.
That's pretty much at bill.
Uh,
that is if your question implied in inherent and attraction between the two,
if it's just like a chance encounter,
like at a party or something like that,
the most interesting man would probably just say it's such an annoying cunt and
he'd be on his merry way.
However,
if the two decided to form a relationship,
the most annoying woman would just siphon everything interesting away from the
most interesting man chiseling him down to a being that could equate her level
of unjustifiable existence.
And then he writes,
wow,
that's depressing.
Uh,
someone should advertise some PSA or something.
There is no shame in a harrowing hunt.
So please do not settle for an annoying country brought to you by the people who
hate cunty throat clearers allocated to their immediate airspace.
Um,
all right,
let's move on with the youtube videos for the week.
I'm going to blow through some topics here just for some people cause I really,
I got to,
I got to tone down the sports on this fucking thing.
It's just becoming the fucking,
uh,
beer and wings podcast here,
a youtube,
youtube videos of the week.
Uh,
look at garbage day original.
All these,
by the way,
we'll be up in the MM podcast.com look at garbage day original.
And this one right here,
this one is from me.
And I think this is one of the greatest fucking lines ever uttered in,
uh,
in movies ever.
Certainly in any sort of teen movie that was a,
that's about teens rebelling.
This movie's called over the edge.
I believe it came out in 1979.
Oh yeah,
this was over the edge.
1979 part nine.
And,
uh,
and just looking at that and you know,
I also started off with revenge of the nerds.
That speech on this podcast that kind of made me just think of some classic
movies could embed.
Uh,
here's ALP look up Al Pachino,
a great ass extended version.
Um,
one of the greatest actors of all time with one of the worst performances I've
ever seen in my life.
And,
uh,
what else do I got?
Incident at subway.
Check that one out.
Some kid at subway wants to fight somebody behind the counter at Jesus on,
I know what's going on.
Um,
Nino.
Uh,
what else?
Underrated.
Overrated.
What happened to this podcast?
Something at 22 minutes happen at this podcast.
You know what it is.
As I went outside,
I'm still wearing my fucking hooded sweatshirt and I think I'm getting too
fucking hot and it's siphoning all the god damn funny up.
But now I can't take it off because they had my fucking headphones on.
So I gotta lay the microphone down as they slowly take this.
All right,
here we go.
Now I'm ready.
Oh,
I remember what I was going to do.
I was going to tell you guys the story this week.
I did this awesome,
unbelievable fucking Gig.
Um,
it was,
uh,
the Bob Woodruff Fund,
whatever he called,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
I really thought that this story was going to get the podcast go.
And again,
what the fuck was it called?
The Bob Woodward f a charity fund auction thing.
Bob Woodward was a reporter.
Uh,
he was in Iraq.
He got hit by a roadside bomb,
made a miraculous recovery.
And this is the fourth annual one where they raise money for his foundation.
That's the word I was looking for his fucking foundation to raise money for it,
for,
uh,
you know,
for troops who have been injured in battle and that type of thing.
Just one of those,
those,
those charities,
you just cannot say no to.
You have to do it.
And,
uh,
it was all the way back in New York City at the Beacon Theater,
for music fans out there.
They know that the Allman brothers had been doing the beacon run for like the
last 30 fucking years.
So already I'm thrilled to be there just because I'm gonna be standing on the
same stage as Duane almonds.
And,
uh,
and I showed up in the,
in the lineup that I went on was the most insane lineup I've ever been on.
Um,
in my career.
This was the lineup.
All right.
Max Weinberg was there and he put together this big band,
so they're out there fucking killing it.
Jon Stewart was the host.
He goes out and he kills it.
Talking about politics in a very funny way,
unlike the Horse Shit that I did on my podcast,
a,
he fucking kills it.
Then he brings out Tony Bennett.
Tony fucking Bennet,
who sings two songs,
absolutely kills it,
sounds as good as he did 40 50 years ago.
Just kills it.
Then they bring out John Stewart comes back out,
does some more jokes,
kills again.
Then he brings out Bruce Springsteen.
Fucking Bruce Springsteen goes out there and just fucking owns the stage,
sliding around,
jumping up on the piano,
tells and telling jokes,
just just fucking kills it.
Uh,
then they had an auction,
at least fucking rich people's played like 150 grand for one of Bruce
Springsteen's guitars,
raised all this money.
Then the second half of the show,
they bring out Joel Mchale who had to go on after Tony Bennett and fucking Bruce
Springsteen,
and he still somehow killed it.
Then I went up and then the final act of the evening was Jerry Seinfeld.
Well,
it's the do Jerry fucking Seinfeld,
the king,
the master,
right.
And I'm on stage when I went out there and my whole nervousness of the night was
not going on after those people was my nervousness was the fact that nobody had
said fuck yet.
And it was a benefit,
you know,
and people talking about tragedy and I was going to go out there and my opening
bit was talking about,
you know,
hitting women.
So I'm backstage just like mind fucking myself going,
Oh God,
going to be too harsh.
I shouldn't curse.
Jerry's going to get mad at me the second I curse.
He's gonna look at me like I'm not even a comedian,
you know,
and I so badly want his fucking approval,
you know?
So I'm sitting there freaking out.
Finally,
my agent just goes,
dude,
Geez.
See what Springsteen just did?
He went out,
he just does what he does,
jumps on pianos.
Just go out there and do what the fuck you do.
I was like,
you know what?
You're right.
So I went out there and I,
I definitely,
I didn't say fuck as much as I usually did,
but I went out there,
I did my getting hit by women,
uh,
hitting women,
all that type of shit,
a fucking killed.
And when I get off stage,
I'm walking and cherries going on next.
So I'm walking off the stage and there he is fucking Seinfeld
who at this point it's,
it's like,
it's like looking at Elvis Goddamn icon is standing there and his suit just
ready to go to work.
And I walked by him.
I'm just,
I'm just wincing waiting from just completely blow me off or just be like,
why did you say fuck so much?
You know?
And I walked by him and he fucking sticks his hand out and he just goes really
funny stuff.
Really,
really funny stuff.
And I was just like,
oh,
thanks a lot.
You know,
I try not to curse so much out of respect for you going on,
going on next.
And he goes,
well I don't care.
Then it felt like an idiot.
I'm sitting in and I'll nervous like a little schoolgirl now.
Just realize like,
wait a minute,
Jerry has always worked totally fucking clean.
He came up in the late seventies,
right through the 80s with all these,
these barroom hack comics doing blow.
I mean the amount of shit that that guy had to go on after working squeaky
fucking clean.
He can't follow me.
Well what the hell was I thinking?
And now I'm thinking he couldn't follow me.
I didn't think of that.
He would be annoyed and a then I stood there,
you know,
like feeling like I was 90 miles in the air because he said that he thought that
I was funny or that I had good stuff.
And then I watched him go out there and it just absolute,
uh,
not to bring up sports again,
but I guess I have to,
you know,
any port in a fucking storm here,
it was like watching a,
you don't want somebody who's just,
just has the,
they're just the perfect swing.
Perfect jumpshot,
their form or whatever that that's what it was like.
There was just everything that he did,
there wasn't one wasted word.
One wasted movement.
Everything.
Okay,
you want to talk moves,
it's like toy story.
You go to see toy story.
It's like every line in the movie just propels the thing forward.
There's not a line of fat in that fucking script and it's just just like his act
and he goes out there and just,
just absolutely fucking destroyed.
And uh,
it was awesome.
The all the other night that I had that ever compared to,
that was one night I was down at the comedy cellar in the,
uh,
in the village in New York City.
And,
um,
that's the club where if you want to see if go out and see great comedy or if
you want to see a,
possibly somebody super famous that's a comedian,
just drop in and do a set.
That's where I would go.
And it used to happen all the time.
And One night I was down the cellar and uh,
give me name and a lot of names here,
but I never named names of the podcast,
but there's nothing bad about this story.
So Godfrey was hosting the show and um,
you know,
I was supposed to,
I think,
I think it was me,
I was going on next.
But,
uh,
all of a sudden,
you know,
I can't really tell this story without saying the names.
This is basically imagine you sitting in the fucking crowd.
All right?
You just seeing no name hacks like me going up and all of a sudden the host
goes,
uh,
hey everybody.
We've got a very special guest that just dropped by wanting to do like five
minutes.
You might recognize this guy from the hit TV show.
Everybody loves Raymond.
Please welcome Ray Romano and ray walks on stage and the crowd goes fucking
nuts.
Holy Fuck Ray Romano,
right?
And um,
as he's on stage,
Seinfeld and Chris rock show up and they also want to go on,
all right,
this has happened once in 20 years of me doing stand up.
This was the most unbelievable night,
right?
So they go downstairs,
Ray Romano finishes.
So Godfrey goes back up and he kept doing these great intros that was making the
crowd lose his shit.
He goes,
keep going through your mind.
all right,
we got another special guest just dropped in.
You might recognize this guy from the Chris rock show,
please welcome Chris Rock.
And then the fucking place standing ovation.
Holy Fuck.
We got fucking Ray Romano and Chris Rock.
And now at this point,
every comic knows that Seinfeld is waiting in the wing.
So we're all standing there huddled down in the little hallway waiting to watch
this crowd lose.
It's fucking shit like those soccer moms on fucking Oprah,
right?
Chris rock kills it.
Godfrey goes up,
Chris Rock,
everybody crown is like out of breath from fucking laughing.
And then he goes,
uh,
we had another guest dropped by at this point.
People just like,
what the fuck?
Right?
He goes,
you might recognize this next guy from the hit TV show Seinfeld.
And I hear this guy go no fucking way out.
And he goes,
please Jerry Seinfeld.
And like half the crowd almost fainted.
He goes up and just fucking destroyed.
And like people,
I like elated.
They had like,
like when he's done the everybody's faces just like in pain from grilling.
And from,
from,
from grinning.
I swear to God,
this is true story,
right?
So Seinfeld ends and he goes,
I keep it going for Jerry Seinfeld.
He goes,
all right,
you guys ready for more?
Show the crowds like flipping out.
And they go,
okay,
this next comedian and the crowd at this point is so goddamn spoiled.
I'm standing there in the doorway waiting to go on and everybody is trying to
look around my head for somebody famous to come on and he's bringing up me.
He goes,
please,
you know,
you might've seen him on a VH ones.
I love the eighties
MTVs apartment two F please welcome bill burn.
I went on stage and there was just,
there was,
uh,
a noticeable sense of disappointment at that point when I walked up to the mic
and the only way I got out of it was I just addressed it.
I was like,
that's right.
Welcome back to reality.
This is what the fuck you paid for.
And then everybody laughed and like,
all right,
he addressed it.
He addressed the fact that we're disappointed to see him.
And at that point they kind of went along for the ride.
And I swear to God,
an hour later,
Dave Chappelle went up and he went up and that was a
boat.
So that night and the night I just did with a two,
two most unreal nights that I've ever seen in a,
in standup comedy.
I swear to God,
that seller story,
I know it sounds like some bullshit.
I swear to God it's fucking true.
Um,
and I don't know why I'm thinking that you're doubting it.
So if you ever go to New York City and you just want to go out and check out
some fucking comics,
go to the comedy cellar right down on
West third and Mcdougal,
right?
I've said that like 9 million times in my life flagging down a cab back in the
day when you could do eight sets on the weekend every night,
flagging down the cab with your spot money.
Take me to west third and Mcdougal.
Do you want me to think the highway?
No.
You fucking asshole.
It's going to cost me an extra $7.
Okay.
It was a lot of traffic.
All right.
You Dick fucking take the other one.
You son of a bitch.
What do I care?
Someday I'll have my own podcast and I'll be selling ringtones at 99 cents a
whack.
Just raking in the fucking money.
I'm all right.
Let's get to underrated.
Overrated for this week.
Um,
all right.
This first underrated overrated that I'm going to read is a,
this goes,
this transcends the topic of underrated.
Overrated.
Because what you written,
not only did he get to hear this person's underrated,
overrated.
You get to see why having a tragic a childhood and,
okay.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what,
uh,
yeah,
basically that lead you to be fucking hilarious because
all right,
I'm going to just read this shit.
This is,
this is from the same fucking person.
All right.
Underrated.
Your new girlfriend being hotter than your ex girlfriend.
Uh,
that first face to face meeting between them is priceless.
That's right.
She's hotter and skinnier than you enjoy the,
the eating disorder.
You can't.
So right off the bat you'd think it,
wow,
that's kinda harsh.
The fuck.
Where does that come from?
You learn where this comes from and is overrated.
Overrated.
Your Dad telling you he loves you.
I heard you fag.
I'm not saying it back now.
Tell that fat bitch you left mom for to get me a fresh beer.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you right now,
if this dude ever did stand up,
he would be the guy that the comedians hang in the back of the club watching on
stage is the crowds groaning,
laughing their fucking ass off because they're relating to everything that he's
saying.
Those are the two classics.
Those are two fucking classics right there.
Um,
I heard you the first time.
Fag.
I'm not saying it right.
Just completely walled off with the emotions.
Ah,
that's fucking great.
That's a funny guy right there.
You already know it.
You know it.
Anyways,
um,
underrated modern horror movies.
Um,
being that it was Halloween last week,
every channel had a horror movie marathon of some sorts and I watched some of
them.
What happened to horror films?
They used to be scary.
MMM.
It might be that I have grown up,
but I think the real problem is that they spend most of their time trying to
grow out the audience.
Have you actually seen the movie saw?
Um,
the first one was good,
but after that they just try to make you throw up.
I mean,
does the movie really need a two minute sequence of a guy being injected with
acid and melting that that really happened?
That's kind of why I stopped watching it.
I saw the first song and I thought it was interesting and I started to watch the
second one and I'm like,
this is just gross.
This isn't really a scary,
it's like a,
it's like scary.
Like no,
it's like,
and even grosser jackass.
Right?
Does that make any sense?
Af,
let me just keep reading this.
God Damn,
why am I trying this week?
Um,
anyways,
he goes on to say it would be okay if they were unpredictable,
but they always make the killer the most obvious choice choice,
which just makes it obvious.
Did that make sense?
Yes,
it did.
Why did you lose confidence in the end?
Okay.
MMM.
No,
I totally agree with you.
I think the problem with a lot of movies,
both action movies and horror movies,
is that the special effects are so unbelievable now that that's what they focus
on.
This happens,
this happens,
this happens.
And then the fucking special effects that they don't build any suspense,
you know,
and they don't really build the characters where you give a shit about them and
you're rooting for them.
The model,
I just like mentally tap out of most of them and I'm like,
well,
this guy's the lead,
so there's no way he's going to die,
rust.
The movie would be over.
So what's the fucking point of this?
And like I always bring it back to a perfect storm.
Like I could give a shit,
you know,
by the time they got to the wave,
I was like rooting for the wave because I,
I didn't care about their,
their pathetic attempt to try to bring some nobility to these guys who went
fishing.
They just so gloss over glossed over the whole fucking thing I had,
I didn't even give a shit.
So I would agree with you,
sir.
Um,
what else do we got here?
A underrated cane sugar.
Seriously.
So much better than that.
High fructose crap.
Pepsi throwback is awesome.
You know what?
I'm going to try it just because you said that and I'm not even a big soda guy.
I'm underrated going to a concert.
Most people I know have never been,
never had the full concert experience of going to see someone you love and
seeing them live on stage,
killing it and leaving,
uh,
leaving def,
sweaty,
tired,
bruised and loving every second of it.
Uh,
you're probably facing the same problem with people going out to see stand up.
Actually,
I've got to be at Mit.
I've been really lucky.
I've been lucky.
People have been coming out to my shows.
Uh,
but anyways,
he says,
uh,
they think it's going to be the same thing as watching it on TV.
I remember the first time I saw you,
do you stand up?
Act?
Um,
it was also the first time I'd ever seen a comedy show.
I'm paraphrasing because I don't know where I am in the sentence.
First time I ever saw a comic was you about four years ago and the live
experience of seeing someone who is good at their craft,
it's just so much better than,
than watching it on TV.
Well thank you very much sir.
And it's considering you just gave me a little bit of a pat on the back.
I want to thank you everybody who's gone out and is bought my DVD.
My DVD is killing it.
It's still last I checked still in the top 10 on iTunes.
Um,
I can't thank you guys enough.
This one is selling even better than why do I do this sold and I'm all the
emails you guys are sending me about that extra 21 minutes of material that you
didn't get to see.
Basically 25% of the special that you didn't get to see on comedy central.
Uh,
I read all of them.
I appreciate all the uh,
all the kinds of emails and all that type of shit.
It's nice.
It really offsets all the jet fans giving me shit to read.
A nice compliment.
Now a jet fans going to write.
I love the DVD and then I'm going to open it up.
Patriot suck.
I already know you're up to that.
What do you think?
I'm a fucking child.
Um,
but seriously and Christmas is coming up.
So keep buying those DVDs.
It's only like 10 bucks on amazon.com.
And as I stated before,
it makes a great stocking stuffer for someone you don't give a fuck about,
but half to buy a gift for.
Go Out,
bang out six of them for 60 bucks.
There you go.
Frisbee him around.
You can't fuck you.
Dickhead Pussy,
whatever.
Up to six people.
You know
what happened just by the God damn thing.
Okay.
My ringtone was such a God damn flop.
People actually asking me to make another rink tone and I feel like a band
that's scratching their head why they haven't been dropped by their label yet.
Um,
which actually segues us into some of the questions for this week.
If I could find them.
Somebody actually asked me some drum questions.
So bill,
I got three questions for you after I heard your drum battle on youtube and you
didn't suck a,
you seem like a relatively good drummer and extremely good opinionator so I'd
like to ask your opinion on some drum things.
Uh,
what do you think are some of the hardest drum songs to play?
Well for me it would be just about all of them.
Uh,
I,
uh,
the hardest ones I would say.
I would say as far as like for a look at,
I'm going to get actually get into this a little bit cause I really got hardcore
into sports,
you know,
not even remotely concerned about people who could give a shit about sports.
So I'll get into this a little bit.
For the musicians out there is,
I actually found one of the hardest things to do is to have the discipline to
just sit down
and try and make what I could physically play.
Actually sound good because I think one of the,
one of the big things when you're learning an instrument is when you physically
get something down,
you move on to the next thing.
You don't,
you don't stay with it until you can actually make it sound good and make it
sound good to somebody listening to you play it.
You just,
okay,
I got that down.
Bre,
Pam.
Okay,
now I'm gonna move on to the next fucking thing.
Rather than,
you know,
if you learn like a drum fill,
you just get the fill down and you,
yeah,
you play a couple of fucking beats and then you just throw it in.
Yeah,
yeah,
I got that down.
You don't really have it down.
So one of the hardest things for me was having a discipline.
Um,
and it was something I learned when I was watching Steve Jordan play drums and I
was listening to him play something and I was watching it going,
I can physically play what he's playing and what he's playing is actually really
simple,
but I could not make it sound.
1 million is good is he's making it sound right now.
Like he was playing a beat that would actually be considered lame if I played
it.
And the way he played it,
it sounded unbelievably fresh and it would make an entire arena just start
smiling and get into whatever song was being played.
That was the fucking hardest thing is far as trying to get halfway decent at
drums for me.
But as far as,
uh,
just songs that are difficult,
any of the shit by John Bonham,
his footage just so God damn fast and you can catch up with speed,
but you just can't play it the way he fucking plays it.
And I've had unbelievable arguments about people like,
you know,
the coke and Pepsi argument with,
with White Rock drummers is who do you like better?
Bottom or Neil Peart this is way back in the day before all these,
these other kids came along and I just fucking killing it.
And I always pick bond them.
I didn't,
I didn't think Neil Peart was anywhere near him.
I thought Neil Peart was like a fucking technician.
He played right on the beat and it was,
sounded very fucking robotic as opposed to John Bonam who could play once again,
the simplest fucking fill that I could physically do.
But could never play it the way he pleads.
Did they just did,
this is the fucking shit.
It's like watching a great actor.
You know what I mean?
Who,
who could just take like a really just basic fucking monologue and make it the
most interesting God damn like a Christopher Walken or even John Goodman that I
was playing.
Like I sometimes I forget what a great fucking actor that guy is.
Um,
I dunno,
I dunno.
So,
but as far as like songs that I would say it's difficult.
I would say,
uh,
the wanton song is ridiculously difficult and I think most people play it wrong.
They actually leave out one bass drum note where he's playing three in a row and
they only play two in a row at that fucking tempo was fucking ridiculous.
Um,
out on the tiles,
that second fill that he does,
that ends where he plays a fucking triplet with one God damn bass drum is
fucking ridiculous.
And then I also got to admit,
uh,
that drum and bass shit and a lot of stuff that like a,
I like really into like,
uh,
um,
what's his face?
A quest love the shit that he plays.
He's another guy where I think he took like the Steve Jordan thing to like the
next level.
Um,
and he,
he does shit.
I don't even know what the fuck he's doing,
but I don't like fucking stutter in here cause I can't really think of any
specific song.
I'll give you one here that I'm trying,
that I want to break out my double pedal because I don't play double bass.
I just play a single bass drum.
But every once in a while there's a drama comes along that's so fucking good.
It makes me want to play double bass.
And um,
I've actually really,
uh,
gotten into that band,
lamb of God and a,
just to warn some of my older listeners,
uh,
this is that sort of,
that,
that Rah Rah,
Rah,
Rah Rah kind of fucking singing,
but it's not as bad as some of the other guys.
But they,
they got this song called break you and this does have double bass pattern in
the end.
That I just think is the shit and I'm sure all you guys who played double bass,
this is a fucking joke for you,
but this is something,
this is the kind of shit that makes me want to play doubles
base.
Let's see if I got this here.
I can get,
this
just sounds ridiculous the way he's singing.
All right,
here we go.
Listen to this fucking double bass pattern.
This is Chris Adler.
This is one of my new favorite drummers.
I think this is the shit right here.
Listen to this.
Here we go.
That shit right there.
That
and machine guns shift actually figured out what the fuck he's doing,
but I,
that just amazes me that the entire band can be on fucking point like that and I
know you guys are going to hit me with a bunch of other double bass drum players
who are faster or whatever.
I liked their band because the temple that they play at,
it's still fucking music to me because some of those other bands I try to get
into,
but it's maybe my ear isn't ready to hear it,
but the shit is so fucking fast,
dad.
It loses its effectiveness that it stops being music.
It just sounds like a jet
that's like flying by but never passes my ears.
It's just sitting there
in my fucking ears.
So,
uh,
I guess that type of Shit.
Does that make any fucking sense?
Why did I do with it?
What did I do?
Um,
let's get to the next question.
Who are some of the best recent drummers of the past decade?
Uh,
I'll just tell you the guys that I like,
I like everyone from a,
whoever played with those original Chuck Berry's,
I like Ringo,
Charlie Watts.
Uh,
Phil Rudd,
Alex Van Halen,
Steve Gadd,
Vinny,
Vinny Khalida.
Yeah.
Uh,
Steve,
Steven Adler,
Chris Adler,
quest,
the,
so many fucking guys.
Um,
and I'm going fucking blank on all of them.
I really should've made a list.
You know what?
I'll actually,
since two a the MM podcast,
I'll send you a couple of youtube videos of some guys that I think are just
fucking amazing,
uh,
amazing drummers.
But,
uh,
I don't know anybody who gives me the fucking chills when I listened to them and
they,
that,
that's like the big thing and they make me wish that I could fucking do it.
That's,
that's how I judge whether a drummer is good enough.
If they,
if they play some shit and it's so fucking good that in my delusional head,
I start driving down the street,
fantasizing that I'm doing it,
you know,
during the middle of the greatest HBO standup special performance ever.
Then that's,
I get into,
I get into that drummer.
All right.
Number three is good times,
bad times.
The only song that you can play.
I can barely play that side,
but now this,
I can play some other ones.
I don't know.
Did that bore the shit out of you?
Music people who gives a fuck?
Um,
alright.
Advice.
This is going to be the last thing and I'm going to get on with my day here.
MMM,
okay.
Advice Bill,
how's it going?
I hope that wherever you're at,
everything is going swell.
Lol.
All right.
It's kind of a question about a relationship.
Here's my story.
I'm 19 years old,
19 year old female who's been dating a 2021 year old male and we've been
together almost five years old,
g five fucking years.
And she writes fucking ridiculous.
Uh,
fucking ridiculous.
I know.
And our relationship has had its ups and downs,
like any relationship,
but lately I feel like I can't stand them anymore.
Yeah,
that's understandable.
You've been dating.
I'm like half of your fucking life.
Um,
I don't know what's wrong with me or maybe it's him.
I don't know what's going on.
I have no fucking clue.
But he seems to have a really big problem with wheat.
If he isn't high,
he can't think about anything else but getting hi.
Oh God.
Here we go.
His goal in life is to get high as a fucking kite and giggle.
That's a peaceful,
nice fucking goal.
Uh,
she writes,
what the fuck?
I don't want to be dating a weakling who needs a drug,
like who leads a drug like that.
I want a man and I don't know how to tell him that.
Every time I tell them I have a problem with the weed,
we get into a huge argument and I ended up being the bitch.
I just want them to care about me more than he cares about his weed and it's
hurting us financially.
We both only make 300 bucks a week and he's spending 75% of his check on weed,
cigarettes and gas.
I am the breadwinner.
I don't want to be the breadwinner.
I'm so tired of taking care of his dumb ass.
Um,
he doesn't even seem like he's willing to change even a little bit.
What do I do?
I know I probably sound like a complete prude,
but I'm not at all.
Well anyways,
I really hope you read this and can give me some good advice.
All right,
ma'am,
you are dating a fucking loser.
Yeah,
you're dating a loser so you gotta you gotta get out of it.
I mean the only red flag in there is when you said,
I just want him to care about me more than he cares about his weed.
Now
the only question I have there is,
well,
what if he was really into playing guitar?
Would you then be like,
I just want him to care more about me than he does about his guitar playing
because then you know that's actually a red flag with you because you could be
one of those awful people.
Like one of the worst relationships you can seriously be in is when you're
dating somebody who finds your passion to be a threat and then they
systematically like they try to mind fuck you out of basically either your dream
in life all the way down to just a simple hobby that you have just because it
steals focus from you paying attention to them,
which I don't think you are in this.
I think you sound very rational.
You actually said,
I don't know if it's me,
so I don't think you are being like that,
so I have to side with you 100% here.
All right,
let's roll.
Let's,
first of all,
we'll start with your relationship and just,
just completely ignore the fact that he's 21 year 19 you've been together for
five years,
which means when you got together,
you were 14,
he was 16,
which means at some point he was 18 and you are under 18.
So there was some sort of statutory rape going on there,
right.
Uh,
we'll ignore all of that and just get to the fact like,
you know,
I've been,
a lot of my listeners would probably think that I was going to trash you for you
saying that I am the,
I'm the breadwinner.
I don't want to be the breadwinner,
you know,
and I would go,
oh,
typical fucking broads.
You know,
they all talk about how they want to be the independent God damn woman and Yada,
Yada,
and all of a sudden they got to take care of some fucking sponge.
Welcome to my God damn world.
I'm not,
I don't feel that's that,
that you'll like that.
I know what you see a date in a fucking loser.
You're,
you're dating a future,
uh,
subject on cops.
It seems,
you know,
the way you describe him,
it's his,
he shirtless to,
this guy's a fucking loser.
He makes 300 bucks a week.
I'm not judging that aspect of it,
but he spent 75% of it on weed,
cigarettes and gas.
You know,
right now I'm picturing that guy that,
uh,
Matthew mcconaughey played in dazed and confused just hanging around the high
school,
like where the party's at,
man,
you know,
with his cool car.
Um,
yeah,
you got to get out of the relationship,
you know,
and there's nothing wrong as a female if,
if,
you know,
I'm not saying that you go out and just be a fucking gold digger,
but she wants you man to be able to provide.
That's what the fuck we do.
We provide,
we don't provide,
we're useless.
We don't have a womb right now.
Seriously.
We're fucking useless.
So I,
uh,
I get it.
Yeah,
you got,
you got to break up with this guy.
You mean,
how many times can you already,
it seems like you're approaching this guy on eggshells.
You know,
he'd be really nice if you,
you know,
if you just stop being a fucking loser,
you'd been aren't even saying that you being a nice person.
So if I had to give you any advice,
I would say you need to get out of that relationship and considering you've been
in it since you're 14,
I think a,
you might be a little codependent and I think you need to to break up with this
guy.
Figure out who the fuck you are,
which will involve you staying single for a significant period of time and uh,
and just know that you know,
breakups are painful.
Just prepare yourself for that so you don't go running back to this fucking
loser and waste another five years of your fucking life.
Cause you don't want to go through six weeks of pain just,
you know,
as they said and platoon take the pain.
All right,
just get out of the fucking relationship and just,
just tell yourself,
this is going to suck for six weeks.
I'm going to wake up crying.
I'm going to feel lost.
I'm going to be wondering what did I use to do with all my free time before I
was with this person.
You can have that bizarre feeling where now you're looking back on somebody who
was a huge part of your life and now they're becoming a stranger.
So then it just becomes this weird episode.
Like what was that?
Who was that?
What the fuck was that my life that just went into that fucking room for five
years?
It's really buzz.
Just prepare yourself that that's going to happen,
but every day it gets a little bit fucking easier.
And then one day you're going to wake up.
You're not going to give a shit.
The Sun's going to be shining.
And uh,
and then just a joy being single.
Your only fucking 19 years old is no fucking reason to be in a relationship
that's serious for that fucking long with the fucking loser.
So get out of it,
get through the pain.
And then after six weeks,
you know,
just hanging out with your friends,
have a good fucking time,
but do not get into another relationship.
I wouldn't get into another relationship for like a year.
Just be single for at least a fucking year and feel how awesome that is to just
be single,
to wake up,
you know,
feel good about yourself but then not have to worry that someone else's a dose.
So that drags down.
You're feeling good about yourself quotient.
Yeah.
It just fucking be single.
All right.
There you go.
I said the same thing 90 times in a fucking roll.
I realize it.
And a,
what are we going?
I'm a little over an hour here on the podcast,
so good luck to Ya.
All right.
Uh,
that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I will talk to you guys next week.
This weekend I am at the funny bone in Columbus,
Ohio.
And uh,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday are the dates that I'm going to be there.
And actually those are the days.
Here are the actual dates.
November 12th,
13th and the 14th and on the 13th I'm going to try to go to that Ohio state,
Penn state game.
You know,
cause I've,
I've been to Ohio state game,
but the first time I went they played bowling green.
It was like the middle of September,
one of those cupcake games and it's sucked.
So I want to go there and get the full on horseshoe fucking experience.
So that is it.
Thank you guys for all the emails.
Thank you so much for buying my DVD.
If you haven't bought it yet,
it's only 10 bucks.
I swear to God.
Yeah,
you're,
you're not going to be upset if you buy this fucking thing and you're really be
helping me out because I will get another deal to shoot another special that you
can then watch and enjoy.
See how it works.
A little surf in fucking turf here.
Beautiful.
All right,
I'll talk to you guys next week.
So close so close.